all right this is pretty cool i'm going
to show you
how to make your own vitamin d
supplements
using
mushrooms
now mushrooms are normally grown in the
dark and the only light they see is some
fluorescent light when they're either
being
picked or processed and mushrooms have
uh very insignificant amounts of vitamin
d
unless you expose that mushroom
to
ultraviolet b
light and there's some very cool
research
on
exposing these mushrooms to light and
boosting the vitamin d levels
to levels far greater than the rdas
you can boost the vitamin d and
mushrooms
to
levels of 5 000
international units
to 46 000
international units and beyond and so in
this video i'm going to show you exactly
how to do it you can use oyster
mushrooms
shiitake mataki
or button mushrooms and there's other
mushrooms you can use as well and when
they did the research and exposed
mushrooms to light they found that if
you expose the gills the little ridges
underneath the cap
you get the maximum conversion to
vitamin d now because the button
mushrooms don't have those little gills
we're going to cut them or slice them
lengthwise to expose more surface area
to create a similar effect now i will
say that the type of vitamin d mushrooms
have is vitamin d2 and so it's a
slightly different version of vitamin d
and it's not as bioavailable and it has
a shorter
half-life but that's okay because you're
going to be boosting the levels of
vitamin d
at a really good range so the amount of
absorption you're going to get is going
to be pretty good i'm also going to
recommend that you consume your
mushrooms with some type of fat like
butter sauteing your mushrooms simply
because vitamin d absorption is
increased when you add a fat since
vitamin d is a fat soluble vitamin but
mushrooms have some pretty good
nutrients
it has a really good range of b vitamins
it has selenium
zinc
copper
that has the vitamin c complex and it
has potassium and many other nutrients
and they're great on keto because
they're low net carb all right so this
is how you're going to do it
you number one you're going to obtain
mushrooms either from the store or
finding them in the woods or you're
going to grow them yourself like i did
recently but i recommend them shitake
mataki oyster or the button mushroom now
in order to have this mushroom
create this conversion and spike the
vitamin d
you're going to need
ultraviolet b
light
and unfortunately you're not going to
see much of that in the winter or you're
living in certain latitudes and parts of
the world in the north so i'm going to
recommend that you do this during the
summer months
but you can also do it in the winter
using a uv
light
so if it's summer june july august
so what you're going to do is you're
going to take your mushrooms
face up you're going to take the stems
off so the gills are pointing upward
and the cap is towards this sheet like a
cookie sheet for example so you want to
take the stems out because the stems
don't really give you much vitamin d but
the gills do so this is mainly for the
shiitake the mitaki or the oyster
because the button mushroom doesn't have
the gills if you're going to use the
button mushroom i would slice them
lengthwise okay so you're going to lay
them down on a cookie sheet and you're
going to put these mushrooms out in the
sun okay
between 10 o'clock in the morning
to
six o'clock
in the early evening that will give you
eight hours of exposure to prime sun
which is exposure to uvb
radiation so at six o'clock you're going
to take this tray back into the house
maybe you cover it you want to make sure
there's not a lot of moisture because
you're trying to sun dry these mushrooms
then the next day day two you're going
to bring them back out in the sun and do
the same procedure expose them to this
bright sun between ten o'clock in the
morning to six o'clock in the evening
then you're going to bring them back to
the house
and hopefully they're completely dried
out the way that you know that they're
dried out is you can just snap them in
half and they should be pretty crisp if
they're still soggy then you might need
to use a dehydrator to completely dry
them so once they're completely dry
which they normally should be on the sun
after two days
you want to put them in a glass jar and
seal the lid
i also recommend putting a little bit of
just rice at the bottom maybe about this
thick just to help you absorb the
moisture
because moisture reactivates the
mushrooms and we're trying to put them
in a dry state
to dehydrate them so they'll last up to
a year
so once you get them in this glass
container
now you preserve them for a good amount
of time but they found that if you
actually keep drying these mushrooms out
in the sun day three four five
the level of vitamin d goes down
dramatically so you only want to do this
for two days
now if it's not during the summer time
you can buy a uv light and do the same
exact procedure but check this out
a hundred grams which is like roughly
one cup of shiitake mushrooms
can give you up to 46 000 ius of vitamin
d2
i mean that is
incredible
now when you use a
light that has uv b radiation and you
expose shiitake mushrooms for 18 hours
now i hope you're sitting down for this
you could potentially boost the vitamin
d2
that's well over 200 000 iu's of vitamin
d this is mind-blowing but that's the
potential conversion
if you did do that
and let's say for example you didn't eat
a cup let's say you ate just a small
amount
that'll give you a tremendous amount of
vitamin d
and you made this vitamin d in your own
home now if you do this procedure to
button mushrooms you'll get a little bit
less you'll get about 20 000 ius
now in other studies
they're just using mushrooms that are
not drying out they'll expose
just fresh mushrooms
in the sun
for between 15 and 120 minutes and
they'll get levels between 600 ius to up
to 5 000 ius just from a shorter period
of time
and this is without exposing the gills
it's just putting the mushrooms out in
the sun
so the whole point and the whole concept
of this is to expose mushroom to the sun
or some light that has uvb radiation
so now that you know how to make your
own vitamin d2
the next thing is to understand fully
the benefits of vitamin d
and i put that video up right here check
it out
you